hello everyone after I did the video the
metaphysics of Pepe with dr. Jordan
Peterson I received quite a few requests
to do more symbolic interpretations of
proper popular cultural phenomena until
today I've been mostly interested in the
symbolic structures that we find in
Christianity in the traditional stories
traditional forms and it has led me to
look into mithilai mythological ideas
folk stories traditions from Islam and
from Judaism as well and so in my wish
let's say to discover the symbolic
pattern that we find in Christianity
I've also found that these patterns are
general patterns of being and we can use
them to understand our lives and our
families but also cultural forms such as
movies and novels and even political
events so when I started to get those
comments at first I hesitated to start
let's say profusely commenting on
popular culture but I realized it to be
honest I do it for myself all the time I
can't watch a movie or a television show
without seeing the underlying pattern so
I thought I would make a more popular
discussion on the question because we
live in a very strange time a time of
rising chaos let's say and by looking at
the patterns which appear around us we
can start to make sense of what's
happening and I hope though I hope that
that as I start making these videos it
will be an impetus for people to look
more deeply into the traditional stories
because let's say something like the
Bible the the level of symbolism and the
level of the stories in the Bible are
far more profound and subtle than
anything that we can find in popular
culture today so having said that first
I need to explain that there are many
ways that we could frame symbolic
patterns and but the frame that I will
use most prominently is the geometric
symbolism of center and periphery and
I'm going to use that structure because
well it's easy to understand
and we encounter it in our bodies we
encounter it in our rituals our
societies and we also encountered more
abstractly in language and in our
concepts and so it also happens to be
the main let's say imagery used by
political factions within the growing
chaos and strife which surrounds us this
notion of identity of refugees walls
immigrations war technology all of these
things can be understood quite well
using the basic frame of center and
periphery in general the the the problem
of chaos is a problem of the margin and
whether we see this margin as an
exciting potential at which we can
further ourselves out into the world or
whether we see this margin this
periphery as a dangerous threat to work
to the things that we care about it's
important to understand the margin and
see its manifestations and I think that
that's the key to avoiding the worst so
I'm going to start these videos with
guardians of the galaxy
so why guardians of the galaxy well it's
the last movie that I saw but it also
has a lot to say about what's happening
around us so there's been a lot of
commentary recently about how a lot of
the blockbuster type movies right now
are giving in to left-leaning social
justice type propaganda and we can
definitely see that in guardians of the
galaxy but it remains interesting
nonetheless and you can still help us
understand things if we stay critical
and make an effort to always see both
sides that's really the key to remaining
aware and being completely aware of
what's happening one of the things that
makes it interesting is its use of the
superhero genre the hero genre the
notion of this of the superhero as a
guardian is quite appropriate a guardian
stands on the wall right stands on the
limit protects the city or
this case right protects the whole
galaxy from whatever threatens it and so
in this way the hero is very much akin
to two to liminal symbolism to symbolism
of the margin like a wall or a weapon is
a manifestation of what happens on the
margin and in fact the hero usually is
not normal the hero is not a proper
extension of the center let's say not a
proper extension of identity rather the
hero is an exception and being an
exception that exception manifests
itself in ways which refract which
reflect the quality of a margin so
Superman is an alien Wonder Woman is an
Amazon Aquaman is from Atlantis so and
so many others of the superhero types
are born from accidents that they're
freaks right like dr. Manhattan or our
Hulk and so many of the superheroes they
suggest a type of hybridity right the
type of hybridity that happens on the
margin on the place where two categories
meet that's where hybridity begins to
occur and so we can see that in the
names of the superheroes like Batman
spider-man etc etc not just a man but as
something man and usually that's
something that say it's an animal or
it's a power or some some something
strange let's say and the heroes in
antiquity the heroes of mythology you
know of the pre-christian world were
also these hybrid things they were
usually demigods right ambiguous hybrid
beings that that stand between between
worlds Heracles Achilles but we also see
that in the Bible and the pre diluvian
Giants right they were called men of
renown and and were known for their
extraordinary feats and they were born
of the miscegenation between the sons of
God and the daughters of men whatever
you think that means it doesn't matter
what's important is to understand that
they are this last generation before
the end of a world this limit of the
world and being at the end of the world
before its destruction they appear as
this mixture of categories as a place
where the categories begin to fall apart
and in the biblical Giants they also
remind us that the the superhero usually
ism is a mere reflection of the
supervillain let's say like two sides of
a coin or rather two sides of a wall and
that sometimes the difference between
what's on one side of the wall and
what's on the other isn't that obvious
and that was certainly the case in
antiquity a great modern example is the
figure of Hellboy who defends the world
from evil but it's basically a demon who
crossed over from Hell and in the end it
is said that he will be the cause of the
end of the world itself and so he
remains ambiguous throughout his story
the recent Suicide Squad movie was a
perfect example of this now in the
guardian of the galaxy the characters
exhibit this in-between nature this
ambiguous ambiguity of the margin you
were so used to the trope of like a
ragtag gathering of contradictory
figures weirdos Outsiders criminal
loners all these these these kind of
these chaotic characters coming together
then we're so used to seeing it now as a
trope and stories that we we probably
don't ask ourselves what that is what
that means
so the basic superhero story usually
let's say the one that comes to mind if
we think right away of us of a basic
superhero story that we could say the
most archetypal story would be this
notion that there is a threat from the
periphery there's a something from the
margin which threatens the center
something monstrous is that is attacking
so think of Independence Day think of
Pacific rank rim and those types of
movies of this invading outer this
invading stranger this invading alien
that comes and the hero saves us from
that thing
if the movie is a bit subtle the
superhero or the hero in general will
have some link will have some
relationship of identity or of causality
with that bad thing that's coming now
think think for example of Superman who
saves the world from General Zod who is
a who also comes from his world think of
the x-men who have the save who have to
save the world from Magneto and other
mutants who are just like them so now
because the superhero is an in-between
character you can also sometimes defend
the world not from the outside threat
but from the dangers and the pathologies
of the center itself or sometimes the
hero can defend the world from both
extremes at the same time what made the
x-men movie so interesting for example
is that the x-men are trying to defend
the world from bad mutants who are like
them
those bad mutants want to destroy the
center let's say they want to destroy
the normies and then the x-men are also
protecting the mutants from those
normies from those in the center who
fear and are disgusted by the mutants
because they're dangerous freaks so a
large part of the story arc of volume 2
of guardians of the galaxy is to show
the pathologies of the center let's say
that the pathologies of identity now we
know that this is what the movie is
about because it's encapsulated in the
catalyst of the story the catalyst of
the story is that the guardians are
hired to protect the source of energy
some batteries belonging to the
sovereign race they protect them from an
interdimensional monster a monster of
chaos to Dragon basically in terms of
symbolism but when the guardians
encounter the queen of the sovereign
race something goes wrong the sovereign
race is presented as this pure race
there they're golden they're designed
and so they're they're intentional and
intentionality is important in
understanding the center but here this
intentionality is is shown to us in the
extreme so think eugenics they're
presented as without error with
accident and the Queen criticizes the
origins of the Guardians speaks of
Quinns unorthodox and unknown genealogy
a hybrid and so particularly reckless
she said so notice the relationship
between hybridity the unknown and chaos
so rocket has himself stolen the
batteries and mate and then he makes us
understand that his theft is a kind of
vengeance against the sovereigns
pretension and pride so the Klean fails
to understand that it is precisely
because this group of guardians are
unorthodox and peripheral which makes
them capable of defending the sovereign
from that monster but it's also what
makes them capable of stealing the very
thing that they were protecting so the
question of identity becomes the central
question of the movie from the beginning
and it plays itself out as the story
unfolds so one side of the pathology of
the center could be called the feminine
side being unpolitical II correct but
using traditional categories who could
call it the passive side of identity in
which which is the desire to remain pure
right to preserve absolute order remain
untouched in an almost hygienic manner
one of the the the traditional images of
this is of course the image of virginity
so when the queen is forced to go and
and of course the queen is a virgin
that's made explicit in the in the story
so when the queen is forced to go to
another planet we see her walking on a
carpet unrolled before her actually
refuses to touch anything foreign you
know we can find this type of excess in
our in our daily relationships we have
the trope that we find around us of the
of the mother who is a clean freak and
we can understand this access in terms
of hygiene
very well we know that the excess of
Hygiene in the modern world the the
excessive use of disinfectants for
example seems to be the at least one of
the causes of modern allergies and so
excess of purity actually causes in a
reaction an excess of our defense system
which reacts disproportionately - - to
things that are actually not harmful or
even beneficial which come from the
outside and there's a story in the Bible
about this a story about the excess of
purity Moses has married a foreign woman
in fact she's a couchette woman who has
been described in tradition as being
Ethiopian woman so she's a woman with a
dark complexion and Moses his sister
Miriam complains about this and because
of this criticism she's punishment and
and her punishment is an appropriately
it is a skin disease her skin becomes
white as snow and so she is defiled by
an excess of whiteness her excess of
purity becomes a punishment and she has
to be kept out of the camp for seven
days so the other enemy if other
important enemy and guardians of the
galaxy is ego ego is in many ways the
flipside of the pathology of the center
the act the active or masculine excess
of the center and that can be described
as the excess of imperialism so if the
Supremes want to protect their energy
they want to protect their lineage
protect their identity at any cost from
let's say leaking out ego which is of
course a perfect name in what he
represents in this movie wants rather to
spread his light throughout the entire
galaxy so that the galaxy becomes
himself he wants his identity to be all
containing no difference at all this is
of course the Tower of Babel motif
he joins himself with all possible
life-forms not with the purpose of
creating new things because he killed
the offsprings in which he does not see
himself right
he will only tolerate that which is a
manifestation of his own identity so he
doesn't understand what he doesn't
understand is that for them for there to
be another version of him that is the
very notion of other means that there
must be different and it is that basic
blindness of pride which makes it
impossible for him to even conceive that
quill would be attached to his humanity
would be attached to the manner in which
he is different from his father and so
ego could not foresee his own demise now
these two pathologies of the center are
obviously in many ways opposites but in
the end they're just passive and active
size of the same pathology which can
come from the excess of the center the
excess of the right hand let's say the
excess of order the excess of identity
and both of these tendencies and their
excesses are totalitarian in the very
explicit sense that is they want to
believe that something can exist on its
own can be completely self-sufficient
which is impossible of course except for
the infinite or the divine itself now
the question is is there something and
key Western is there something anti
order or is there some social justice
propaganda in this movie maybe a little
I there seemed it seems to be let's say
strongly tilted to one side but the
chaos of the margin is also showed we
see that in the mutiny of the Ravagers
against yondu that's a good example of
the chaos that happens in in the margin
also we see it in the resentment and the
bitterness of nebula who's also a half
biological half robot creature
but it's also lurking in the background
of this movie because we know especially
if we've seen the first movie we know
that behind all this lurking behind all
of this story are the is basically the
head of the forces of chaos I would say
which is Santos which is which is a
version of death and so despite the
strong left-leaning tendency some
balance is still find in the overall
story and we'll have plenty of time to
look at the excesses of both sides if we
continue on this series so that's my
first attempt of doing this of giving a
little bit of symbolic interpretation of
a movie and so let's say all of your
reaction will decide whether this is
worth it
and also what direction I'm going to go
with this so please like comment share
subscribe to my channel all the things
that will help me decide if this is
worth it and I hope to see you again
soon
you